so I guess you could sum up optimizing
the critical rendering path as having
three main objectives reducing the
number of critical bytes reducing the
number of critical resources and
shortening the critical path length
exactly so your job is to make the
critical rendering path as small and as
short as possible it definitely okay so
I'm going to go back and run my page
through PageSpeed insights again and
this time I'll get some recommendations
that I can act on and I can't wait to
start optimizing my site awesome I'm
glad to hear that where performance is a
big topic and there's a lot more to
learn so when you go through page speed
insights make sure you follow the links
to learn about other things it all adds
up in the end are you ready to do the
final project yeah of course all right
now that we've taking the full tour
through the critical rendering path I
think you've got all the tools you need
to make the site render as fast as
possible ideally in under one second
and Cameron's portfolio site needs a lot
of work if we run it through PageSpeed
insights we see that as scoring pretty
low as a final challenge use what you've
learned in this class to help me
optimize my site your goal is to improve
the PageSpeed insights score above a 90
right and to do this you'll need to do a
few things first fork the project see
top repo you can find a link to it in
the instructor notes
then analyze it using the techniques
like drawing the critical rendering path
diagram and diagnosing the critical path
metrics then apply the optimizations and
publish it on github pages if you're not
familiar with github you can find some
links in the instructor notes helping
you fork the repo and publish your site
on github once you finish your
optimizations run your new and improved
portfolio through the PageSpeed insights
you'll see all sorts of suggestions that
should make some sense now
like optimized CSS delivery and remove
render blocking JavaScript when you
think you've done all the optimization
you can post what changes you made on
the forums along with the URL of your
portfolio and the new PageSpeed insight
score and while you're at it why don't
you make the portfolio page your own you
can use it to showcase the projects
you're proud of we've got a link in the
instructor notes to help you out good
luck